[Musique]
bonsoir francesco rizzotto merci devrait
avec nous en direct sur arte france une
première réaction tout d'abord à ce plan
présenté par boris johnson assez prudent
trop prudents maintenant vous faut je
pense que c'est un plan prudent et pour
moi le premier ministre a aujourd'hui
développer la feuille de route donc
soumise à plusieurs critères à qui se
déroulera entre aujourd'hui en fin juin
donc ce calibre et emea conditions si
cela fait sens
mais c'est effectivement une feuille de
route qui offre une sortie donc c'est
positif
alors c'est vrai que nous aux français
pardonnez moi on est fasciné par cette
feuille de route très précise qui va
jusqu'en juin fin juin
ici celle inverse on agit en fonction
des chiffres
le fait d'avoir un calendrier ça rassure
les anglais comment réagit style à ce
plan locke affecte un showman ipi pour
avoir une feuille de route je pense que
cela arrange beaucoup de monde heureux
la lueur au bout du tunnel semble être
apparue aux donc de ce point de vue les
gens sont heureux où nous pourrons
partir en vacances d'ici à fin juin pour
rejoindre cob en mai ne pourra nous
faire couper les cheveux en avril et à
partir du 2 mars nos enfants pour nous
se rendre à l'école donc c'est une forme
de libération
cependant le gouvernement et la
population ne doivent pas refaire
l'erreur de croire que
c'est fixé nous serons libérés c'est la
soeur à la fin gouvernement a espacé
quatre étapes de cinq semaines et les
insoumises à quatre critères très
importantes qui doivent être remplies
toutes les cinq semaines
le déploiement du vaccin doit continuer
vaccin doit lui taux d'hospitalisations
et de décès
loto de contamination ne doit pas
repartir à la hausse afin que les
hôpitaux on puisse continuer à traiter
les malades afin que le nhs ne soit pas
submergés et bien sûr nous ne devons pas
voir arriver de nouvelles vagues de
nouveaux variants qui pourrait saper
l'action du vaccin
donc ce sont des critères très rigoureux
très exigeant et cette feuille de route
une suivra ce calendrier que si ces
quatre critères sont respectés
l'expérience suggère qu'ils meurent à
des variations cependant effectivement
c'est une sortie c'est une issue mais
l'aco vide nous a appris que rien n'est
jamais aussi aime aussi gravé dans le
marbre qu'on aimerait le croire
en france si je peux en revenir à cela
le problème c'est que la façon dont le
français les italiens l'ont fait pose
problème en europe les entreprises
pharmaceutiques ne produisent pas les
vaccins à un rythme suffisant c'est en
deçà des progrès des promesses et
d'autre le programme de vaccination va
être plus long c'est tout simplement
cela et c'est celle à cause du grand
conflit entre la commission et les
entreprises pharmaceutiques
on a de l'avancé mais il y aura des
conflits concernant ce que j'ai dit il
ya quelques semaines un dans une autre
truc notre entretien environ en dix ans
n'est pas qu'il n'y aurait pas de
nationalisme vaccinale c'est ne pas tout
à fait du nationalisme vaccinale mais
les entreprises pharmaceutiques ne
jouent pas franc jeu pour tout le monde
enfin le chat sur les autos surtout vous
on est en sortie de l'europe vous n'avez
vous dû vous mettre d'accord qu'avec
vous même mais la france dû se mettre
d'accord avec les 26 autres pays de
l'europe est ce que c'est pas là que le
bât a blessé
justement il fallait faire jouer la
solidarité européenne celui d'en face on
april avantage n'est pas pour des
raisons complètement idéaliste et piller
les réalités la réalité est la suivante
au royaume uni 33% de la population a
été vaccinée soit 17 millions mais nos
frontières sont fermées
l'autre économie est en souffrance donc
partir tout seul de son côté n'est pas
forcément la solution
car si on joue solo mais qu'on n'ouvre
les frontières le fax un bar entre le
virus soit résolu hier donc la solution
européenne n'était pas mauvaise
la question de l'autorisation trop lente
des vaccins était un problème mais on
peut dire qu'il est mieux de prendre des
précautions et de vérifier quels sont
les effets secondaires avant de
distribuer des vaccins
je pense qu'en europe le véritable
problème c'était le moment que deux
vaccins la baisse des promesses de
provisionnement vaccins et certains pays
ont découvert
ces vaccins selon van tu attendais
marché parallèle c'est un véritable
scandale
le royaume nuit av l avantage parce
qu'effectivement il pouvait prendre des
décisions unilatérales en se pendant
rappelez-vous que plusieurs milliers de
personnes sont morts dans ce pays bien
plus que dans les autres pays de l'union
européenne
donc nous avons payé un prix pour les
erreurs de notre gouvernement et pour
notre soi disant liberté
donc il ya un équilibre difficile à
trouver pour moi je veux cavalier seul
peut protéger mais au bout d'un moment
il faut ré ouvrir ses frontières
et si les autres ne sont pas vaccinés
alors tout le monde souffre merci
francesco risotto professeur de droit
européen université de et jill d'avoir
été avec nous en direct pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir